Patrick's with us in Denver hi Patrick
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show thank
you sir appreciate you taking my call
sure what's up hey again quick question
for you for retirements and investments
I'm 51 years old I'm debt free except my
home I'll about 65,000 on my home I have
about $20,000 in individual stocks I
have an emergency fund of 15,000 have
about 10,000 in savings my monthly
income is $9,000 a month take home and I
would like to have my house paid off in
January to February and start off to
seven 2017 great once I do all of that
and I'm completely debt-free I need to
make up some time I've got about 15 to
17 years to retirement and like the
numbers I stated I have very little say
for the retirement but like you say I
have a huge shuffle I've done real
estate in the past before but I got hurt
in the 2008 2009 but I did I did enjoy
it and it's something that I'm I'm not
afraid to do what percentage of
investing in investing in mutual funds
and in real estate would you do to make
up the ground that I need to make up in
the 15 to 17 years are you married go
okay well first thing I'm gonna do is
follow through on your plan here which
means I'm cashing out the stock and the
extra $10,000 throwing thirty thousand
at your mortgage today leaving you only
a thirty five thousand dollar balance
which you knock out by the end of the
year that sounded like your plan was it
yes I was going to possibly even my
emergency fund a little bit and then I
have a consistent income of about nine
thousand dollars a month so now we now
you and I are sitting in January or so
with a paid for house and a fully funded
emergency fund and we start talking
about a retirement mix with a guy who
loves real estate like I do well at a
minimum I'm going to have you do your
full sixty five hundred you because
you're over 50 you can do sixty five
hundred into your Roth IRA to start with
we do that D F 401k available I just do
myself I'm self-employed of 1099 I would
be able to do a set
all right I would I would definitely do
a Roth IRA and I would start thinking
about a SEP here's the interesting thing
about the SEP you can load that thing
full and when it gets enough in it you
could set up a self-directed SEP that
allows you to buy real estate with cash
inside of that ooh
so I'd load them I'd load them both up
because you got to save up the money to
pay cash for the real estate if you're
listening to me because we already got
your house paid for we're not going to
turn and go in debt to buy rental
properties you've already been on that
train you didn't like that ride so but
now the trick is this you know a we
let's say we build up some money and you
buy a hundred thousand dollar house
inside yourself a self-directed self you
can do that however the entire SEP or
the entire rental property has to be
operated as a part of your retirement
plan meaning you don't make any of the
money off the rent it goes back into the
SAP okay the rent goes back into the
step the Recep Bey is the expenses for
operating the rental and the net profits
on the rental property stay in the SAP
until you're 65 to 59 and a half but
you're coming up on that or coming up on
that pretty quick anyway so then you
could pull it out of there if you wanted
to and do all the but if you as long as
you roll the stuff over inside the SEP
there's no taxes on it and if you do a
Roth SAP they'll never be any taxes on
your gains no way yeah way this is very
cool Wow
this will completely work but now here's
the problem okay we're betting real
heavy on real estate and so far you
hadn't done good at that correct
so just be careful my brother I don't
want you end up when those broke people
playing on the real estate right so
we're paying cash for it you take your
time when you're buying real estate the
money's made it to buy it's not made at
the sale you steal it or you don't buy
it that's the rule you buy real estate
cheap that's where your money is made
you take your time and you are a sweet
person so you are a kind voltar you are
circling and circling and waiting for
something to die and you get a great buy
which right today in most markets mark
it's hot it's hard to find a great buy
out there today three or four years ago
I was buying everything in sight I ran
out of cash because I was just buying
real estate as hard as I could buy and
uh I don't want to wish bad times on the
economy or anything but I really liked
those days because I made a lot of money
on real estate
I hadn't sold any of it so I haven't
made the money but oh man if I got some
equity Wow
wonderful so really you know you catch
real estate in a down market but you're
not ready to buy today anyway you got to
get to the end of the year then you got
to build up that you got a pup fund the
Roth IRA in good growth stock mutual
funds that keeps you diversified
somewhat and then load that set full
load that set full load that's up full
and set it up as a raw and yeah that'll
be sweet if your 1099 with no employees
that you can put thirteen point eight
percent of your adjusted gross income in
there it's it's yeah go see one of our
endorsed local providers they can show
you how to set it up it has to be self
directed at the point that you're ready
to move it into real estate this is the
Dave Ramsey show hey guys thanks for
watching if you enjoyed this video click
the subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show so you have to break
the cycle you have to flip this thing on
its head and make it behave you've got
to get so fired up and wired up that
you're broke friends think you've lost
your mind
you